bonjour à tous à suivre dans un instant
la suite du projet de loi de finance
rectificative pour 2013 collectif
budgétaire s'inscrit selon le ministre
de l'Économie Pierre Moscovici dans un
contexte de reprise timide de la
croissance ce matin a laissé notre ont
terminé la discussion générale puis ils
ont ils ont entamé la discussion des
articles ils ont adopté la première
partie du texte puis ils ont notamment
adopté la réforme de l'assurance vie
l'article 7 du collectif budgétaire
réforme de l'assurance vie en vue d'une
meilleure contribution au financement de
l'économie tout de suite les sénateurs
reprennent les discussions aux articles
additionnels avant l'article 10 très
bonne séance à tous
madame la ministre chers collègues
a été marquée par l'affaire Varens
c'est-à-dire la retraite spéciale dont
devait bénéficier le PDG du groupe PSA
en récompense
j'aurais envie de dire entre guillemets
de ces bons et loyers services
seulement 21 millions d'euros de
retraite chapeau pour Monsieur Varin
c'est une somme importante réunie à
partir de la constitution d'une
provision dite spécifique provision qui
comme tout autre est le produit de la
mise en œuvre d'une réserve d'une partie
du chiffre d'affaires du groupe
c'est-à-dire
si l'on peut dire le travail de ces
salariés les ouvriers de l'usine PSA
dans le nord-est sous bois appelé avoir
fermé leur entreprise avant peu ont
ainsi travaillé pour permettre au PDG
qui a décidé cette fermeture de vivre
une retraite paisible et heureuse il est
donc grand temps nous semble-t-il de
légiférer en matière de rémunération
importante dans le secteur privé nous ne
pensons pas pouvoir faire éternellement
confiance à la sagesse là aussi je
mettrai un guillemet des organisations
professionnelles patronales des comités
de rémunération des conseils de
direction d'administration ou de
surveillance le décalage est sans cesse
croissant dans les plus grands groupes
privés entre les rémunérations les plus
faibles et les plus élevées les études
de l'Insee notamment prouvent que les
hausses de rémunération dont on
bénéficié les détenteurs de très
hauts-salières
soient environ 1% des salariés du
secteur privé les mieux rémunérés se
sont avérés au moins deux fois supérieur
à celle des cadres et des ouvriers et 5
fois plus élevés au moment où ces
salariés connaissaient une promotion
faute d'avoir vu les entreprises privées
faire preuve donc de la plus élémentaire
mesure quant à la fixation des
conditions de rémunération des cadres
dirigeants de nos entreprises nous ne
pouvons que vous proposer l'application
de disposition fiscale dans le caractère
dysphasif et bien entendu l'élément
principal
merci madame Beaufils je vais demander à
notre rapporteur général la vie de la
Commission sur cet amendement
l'avis de la commission madame la
Présidente
mes chers collègues madame la ministre
la ville de la commission est
défavorable puisque nous avons estimé
qu'une imposition à 95%
d'indemnités de départ fixée par voie
contractuelle serait évidemment
j'allais dire confiscatoire mais surtout
un constitutionnel et
nous avons noté que les avantages
indemnités de départ versés aux
dirigeants de société côté font d'ores
et déjà l'objet d'un encadrement et sont
obligatoirement subordonnés à la
performance dans l'entreprise et du
dirigeants
et
sinon j'aurais pu évoquer aussi la
liberté contractuelle et les
prérogatives du conseil de surveillance
de l'entreprise
bien sûr il convient de rester très
attentif aux abus
surtout lorsque ceux-ci se manifeste
dans les entreprises ou l'État est
actionnaire
et l'actualité effectivement vous l'avez
évoqué nous le rappelle avec force mais
ce n'est pas me semble-t-il une taxation
à 95% totalement déconnecté de la
performance des dirigeants
qui permettrait d'assurer
une totale sécurité quand vos exigences
en matière de rémunération donc c'est un
avis défavorable de la commission
si monsieur le rapporteur général madame
la ministre la vie du gouvernement
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs
je ne suis pas au nom du gouvernement
favorable non plus à votre proposition
d'imposer au taux de 95 % les
rémunérations
différé versés aux dirigeants pour la
fraction excédent le montant annuel du
SMIC comme la rappeler à l'instant le
rapporteur d'abord l'encadrement et la
taxation des parachutes dorés des
retraites chapeaux des dirigeants des
sociétés cotées ont été considérablement
renforcés ces dernières années il ne me
semble pas inutiles d'en rappeler
quelques éléments sur le plan juridique
le régime actuel permet tout d'abord de
garantir que les indemnités de départ
des dirigeants ne sont pas indûment
versés mais sont bien indexés ou
récompenses bien leur performances au
plan fiscal en application de l'article
39-5 bis du code général des impôts les
rémunérations différés ne sont admises
en déduction du bénéfice net des
sociétés cotés que dans la limite d'un
montant fixé à 6 fois le plafond annuel
de la sécurité sociale et puis sur le
plan social la contribution patronale
sur les rentes versées au titre des
retraites chapeau s'élève à 32% la
contribution spécifique sur les rentes
élevées c'est à dire celles qui excèdent
huit fois le plafond annuel de la
sécurité sociale c'est-à-dire 296 256
euros pour 2013 s'élève quant à elle à
30% donc ce sont des montants qui sont
importants et puis une contribution a
également été mise à la charge des
bénéficiaires de ses rentes à des taux
qui vont de 7 à 14 % selon le montant
perçu donc toutes ces mesures ont bien
pour objectif d'éviter les abus que vous
aviez raison de souligner dans votre
intervention deuxième point la taxe
obsessionnelle exceptionnelle de
solidarité sur les hautes rémunérations
proposées dans le cadre du PLF pour 2014
a par ailleurs vocation à s'appliquer
aux rémunérations des dirigeants elle
sera un élément de plus pour renforcer
cet effort de solidarité des entreprises
qui versent de haute rémunération et
puis enfin comme la rappeler le
rapporteur taxer à 95% ces rémunérations
sans compter les autres impositions qui
s'ajoutent à l'impôt sur le revenu
serait très certainement confiscatoire
et censuré pour cette raison par le
Conseil constitutionnel donc sous le
bénéfice de ces explications je vous
invite à bien vouloir retirer
l'amendement et à défaut j'en demanderai
le rejet merci merci Madame la Ministre
madame bouffis vous êtes sollicités pour
un retrait que décidez-vous
oui j'ai bien entendu les remarques qui
ont été faites sur un certain nombre de
règles qui ont été mises en place ces
derniers temps et on a
voté pour un certain nombre d'entre
elles ces règles mais à partir du moment
j'ai donc une interrogation à partir du
moment où une entreprise continue à se
permettre de faire de telles
propositions à un moment où on propose
le licenciement
d'une part énorme de ces salariés ça
montre donc il y a quelque chose qui
manque dans le dysplasif la proposition
que l'on faisait c'est pas 95% de la
totalité des indemnités c'était 95% sur
la partie supérieure au montant annuel
du SMIC c'est donc pas le confiscatoire
tel qu'il avait été analysé par le
Conseil constitutionnel à un moment
donné donc sous réserve de l'analyse
plus complète je vais quand même le
maintenir mais on sera attentif à
regarder ce que l'ensemble des éléments
que vous avez rappelé donne comme aspect
dissuasif mais apparemment pour le
moment ça ne suffit pas puisqu'on peut
encore se permettre quand une entreprise
va licencier de faire de telles
propositions c'est bien qu'il y a un
problème
merci madame Beaufils y a-t-il des
explications de vote oui je vous en prie
cher collègue merci madame le Président
je ne prends pas la parole pour défendre
ses retraits de chapeau effectivement
d'un montant très important surtout dans
le cas d'espèces mais ceci étant dit je
trouve que notre collègue madame
Beaufils essaye vraiment de compliquer
la vie du gouvernement
quand on se souvient des difficultés que
le gouvernement a eu pour mettre en
œuvre la fameuse tac à 75% qui devait
d'abord être payé par les bénéficiaires
de co- revenus et qui finalement est ce
qui est quand même un comble devrait
être pris en charge par les entreprises
elles-mêmes ils revenir avec une taxe à
sa 95% même au-delà du SMIC honnêtement
je trouve que c'est entre membre de la
même majorité tout cela n'est pas très
sympathique
merci Monsieur Dallier plus de demandes
de parole je mets donc que l'amendement
aux voix deux avis des favorables qui
est pour le voter
madame Beaufils
contre
merci chers collègues abstention il
n'est pas adopté nous passons à
l'amendement 141 qui défendu par notre
collègue monsieur Delattre
c'était amendement
concerne un sujet bien connu notre
assemblée parce que déjà au cours de
projet de loi de finances eu un large
consensus et hormis le parti socialistes
tout le monde avait voté
l'amendement qui revenait sur
les parts qui étaient accordés dans le
cadre du quotient familial qui ont été
réduites déjà en 2013 rebelote en 2014
et
on trouve ça dommage pour trois raisons
d'abord un problème de démographie notre
démographie quand même à des rares
avantages qui nous reste aujourd'hui en
Europe notamment
et il faut penser qu'un jour il faut la
retraite de par répartition à des
exigences et qu'on a déjà beaucoup de
difficultés de mettre un frein à la
politique familiale de ce point de vue
là c'est des gens un peu discutables
c'est discutable aussi au niveau du
pouvoir d'achat parce qu'en fait les
familles c'est quand même les familles
qui ont des enfants qui consomment qui
faut financer les études etc et tout le
monde sait très bien c'est pas un
problème d'égalité entre les
contribuables c'est un problème
d'égalité entre les familles alors
j'espère que nous allons retrouver une
large majorité pour faire en sorte que
nous passions tout simplement du montant
de 2000 euros qui est inscrit
actuellement et le remplacer par le
montant de 2336 euros qui permettrait
aux cancion familiales de retrouver un
sens économique pour de nombreuses
familles de notre pays
petit chers collègues la vie de la
Commission
oui maintenant la président de la vie
bien sûr défavorable puisque c'est
amendement reprend d'une façon quasi
totale les l'argumentation développée
déjà dans le PLF il va à l'encontre de
la politique familiale telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui
préconisée par le gouvernement et elle a
un impact sur évidemment les finances
publiques et pas négligeables toutes ces
raisons monsieur delat semble dire qu'un
milliard c'est rien ce que j'entends
mais
oui c'est vrai que 10 12 15 milliards
vous êtes pas un milliard prêt pour
dégrader le sol budgétaire donc je vous
laisse faire dans vos propositions en
tout cas et heureusement que le
gouvernement résiste à cette à cette
gourmandise que vous développez ici à
longueur de temps concernant
l'utilisation de ces milliards donc
l'avis que j'aimais aujourd'hui tout à
fait le même évidemment que celui de
avis défavorable mon cher collègues je
vous remercie monsieur général madame la
ministre la vie du gouvernement sur
cette amendement
oui madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs le gouvernement
n'est pas davantage favorable à cette
proposition pour plusieurs raisons tout
d'abord l'abaissement du plafond de
l'avantage procuré par le quotient
familial c'est une mesure qui est
indispensable pour assurer la pérennité
du financement de la politique familiale
tout en préservant l'universalité des
allocations familiales je rappelle que
le déficit de la branche famille s'est
élevé à 2,5 milliards d'euros en 2012
donc il est il était urgent et il est
toujours urgent d'agir pour assurer la
pérennité de notre de notre politique
familiale c'est pourquoi nous avons
demandé à travers l'abaissement de
l'avantage maximal en impôts résultant
de l'application du quotient familial de
2000 euros à 1500 euros un effort de
solidarité au foyer fiscaux les plus
aisés et cette mesure permet ainsi
d'améliorer de près de 1 milliard de
près de 1 milliard d'euros la situation
de la branche famille dès 2014 tout en
préservant l'universalité des
allocations familiales deuxième point la
mesure proposée par la loi de finances
pour 2014 comme celle qui a été adoptée
l'an dernier c'est à mesure de justice
fiscale puisqu'elle concerne uniquement
les foyers fiscaux les plus aisés cette
mesure ne touchera en effet que 13% des
foyers fiscaux ayant des enfants à
charge les ménages concernés
appartiennent aux 30% des ménages les
plus favorisés des plus aisés et donc
pour un pour donner un exemple un couple
marié avec deux enfants le plafonnement
et s'appliquera uniquement à ceux dont
le revenu déclaré est supérieur à 5850
euros par mois la réforme proposée
n'aura donc pas d'incidences sur les
autres familles qui sont non imposables
ou pour lesquelles l'avantage en impôt
procuré par la demi-part pour enfant à
charge est inférieur ou égal à 1500
euros et puis enfin troisième point
cette mesure ne remet pas en cause la
politique familiale à laquelle le
gouvernement est très attaché comme il
le prouve à travers plusieurs décisions
qui permettent de réduire la pauvreté
des familles par exemple la majoration
de 50% du complément familial pour les
familles nombreuses vivants sous le
seuil de pauvreté ou l'augmentation de
25% de la location de soutien familiale
allouée aux familles monoparentales
merci madame la ministre monsieur
Dallier
merci madame le Président Madame nous
sommes heureux madame la ministre de
vous entendre réaffirmer votre
attachement à la politique familiale et
a donc à la familiarisation du de
l'impôt sur le revenu mais cette semaine
me semble-t-il la porte-parole du
gouvernement a parlé d'une nouvelle idée
qui a été mis sur la table récemment on
parle maintenant de la déconjugalisation
de l'impôt sur le revenu et l'argument
qui est avancé et de de dire que cette
le fait de considérer ensemble les
revenus du couple pénaliseraient les
femmes et les inciterait à ne pas
travailler alors on a du mal à s'y
retrouver parce que effectivement vous
touchez au quotient alors ça ne pourrait
toucher effectivement que les hauts
revenus mais pour autant on parle
maintenant des conjugalisations donc on
ne sait plus très bien où veut aller le
gouvernement et on aimerait avoir des
éclaircissements sur vos intentions
réelles en la matière
merci Monsieur Dallier je mets aux voix
cet amendement madame Beaufils madame
Beaufils
oui c'est cet amendement qui est donc
sur le quotient familial est un
amendement que nous avions aussi porté
en loi de finances initiale dans la
mesure où nous pensons en effet que la
justice fiscale
telle qu'on l'appelle de nos vœux c'est
pas sur la partie de la politique
familiale nous sommes-t-il qu'elle doit
porter et par conséquent
cet amendement bien évidemment retrouve
impositionnement que l'on a pris au
moment de la loi de
la loi de finances initiale et il est
évident que nous continuons à penser que
le choix qui a été fait de modifier ce
quotient familial n'est pas celui que
nous nous attendons nous nous pensons
que la réforme de l'impôt sur le revenu
elle doit être en effet sur une
amélioration de la progressivité avec y
compris des tranches beaucoup plus
nombreuses qui permettront de mieux
faire cette progressivité pour répondre
à une plus grande efficacité à une plus
grande justice fiscale
merci chers collègues monsieur Guillaume
vous avez la parole
madame la Présidente je ne peux que
reprendre l'argument du rapporteur
général
vous nous dites à longueur de discussion
qu'il faut baisser les dépenses
publiques et vous en faites une sorte de
veau d'or de veau d'or qu'on adore à
genoux bon mais là en l'occurrence vous
nous proposez de le financer par cette
vieille lune du 575 franchement c'est
pas ça crédibilise pas votre proposition
on peut en discuter on pourrait en
discuter dans le cadre de la réforme de
la de la fiscalité en général ok mais
tant que ces formuler là franchement
c'est pas c'est pas acceptable puis j'ai
l'autre raison pour lequel je ne le
voterai pas c'est que vous avez l'air je
pense pas que ça soit votre idée mais
vous avez l'air de désigner l'Allemagne
comme adversaire c'est ce que vous dites
c'est dans la les motivations mais
l'Allemagne ce sont nos alliés ce sont
nos partenaires et puis il y a bien
d'autres pays en Europe où la natalité
flanche donc voilà c'est pas je crois
que c'est pas une bonne allusion merci
monsieur
plus plus de demandes de parole plus de
monde de parole chers collègues je mets
aux voix l'amendement 141 présenté par
notre collègue Delattre qui a eu deux
avis défavorables qui est pour voter cet
amendement
merci qui est contre
il est adopté
alors j'ai deux amendements mes chers
collègues j'ai deux amendements faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune le
premier n'est pas défendu il tombe le
second est présenté par le groupe
écologiste chers collègues vous pouvez
le présenter c'est le 182 merci madame
la présidente madame la ministre mes
chers collègues c'est effectivement un
amendement identique à celui proposé par
Madame Liman Espana qui est Rossignol la
transition énergétique nécessite de
favoriser les initiatives de citoyens
dans les projets locaux d'énergie
renouvelable initiative qui déjà se
multiplient et crée des emplois dans nos
territoires ces démarches s'inscrivent
le plus souvent dans le champ de
l'économie sociale et solidaire et
répondre à une logique de circuit court
de l'énergie toutefois la réalisation du
montage juridique et financier d'un tel
investissement participatif des
particuliers et je sais que
l'investissement participatif et
particulier tiens particulièrement à
coeur à la ministre assise à ce banc et
cet investissement participatif
notamment des riverains de projet dans
la production d'énergie renouvelable
étant l'état très complexe afin de
faciliter les sorts de tels projets
locaux portés par les citoyens c'est
amendement propose donc d'étendre les
réductions d'impôt sur la fortune
obtenue au titre d'un investissement
dans les PME aux structures de
production d'énergie renouvelable dès
lors que celle-ci bénéficie de
l'agrément entreprises solidaire cela
contribuera à la nécessaire dynamique en
faveur des énergies renouvelables et
accroîtra l'axe et l'acceptation de la
participation active dérivera dans de
tels je vous remercie merci Monsieur
gatolin la vie de monsieur le rapporteur
général sur cet amendement
la vie du rapporteur général est le même
que pour l'examen en PLF puisque c'est
le même amendement et j'en demande le
retrait car l'avantage isfme n'est pas
le bon dispositif pour soutenir les
entreprises même solidaires de
production d'énergie par l'exploitation
des sources d'énergie renouvelables dont
les revenus sont garantis des
amendements donc a été déposé dans le
même sens et ces amendements avaient été
retirés donc je suggère à nouveau à
notre collègue
de raisonner de la même façon et de bien
vouloir retirer son amendement qui me
semble-t-il ne trouve pas sa place dans
ce PLFR puisque on a ici un PLF qui a
vocation à faire des ajustements
budgétaires sur l'exercice 2013 on a eu
cette discussion large sur le PLF 2014
et chacun a pu s'exprimer je crois qu'il
est opportun qu'on renouvelle une
deuxième fois le même discussion avec
les mêmes arguments les uns les autres
donc
mon raisonnement en ce qui nous concerne
et de suggérer le retrait
même un vide du gouvernement madame la
ministre même avis je vous remercie vous
êtes sollicité par deux demandes de
retrait monsieur gatolin
écoutez comme c'est pas moi qui ai mené
les précédents débats donc je donne
crédit aux rapporteur général mais il
nous a dit qu'il y a de meilleurs moyens
pour faciliter alors on aimerait qu'il
soit mise en oeuvre parce que la
transition énergétique est quand même
une des priorités du gouvernement et
donc on aimerait avoir très concrètement
et sans attendre d'année en année de
nouvelles procédures la capacité de
mettre ça en œuvre très concrètement et
d'impliquer les citoyens donc je retire
mais nous reviendrons à la charge avec
comme vous avez proposé de meilleurs
moyens et bien nous attendrons vos
suggestions monsieur rapporteur général
merci Monsieur gâteau la
comptons nous le savons
j'ai deux amendements identiques faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune le
premier n'est pas défendu il tombe le
second monsieur gâteauin vous le
présenter
très rapidement madame la Présidente
c'est amendement est pratiquement
similaire au président précédemment
pardon toujours dans le but de faciliter
les sœurs des projets locaux de
production d'énergie renouvelable il
propose d'étendre la réduction d'impôts
sur le revenu cette fois-ci obtenu au
titre de l'investissement dans les PME
au structure de production d'énergie
renouvelable dès lors qu'elle bénéficie
de l'agrément entreprise solidaire le
coût de cette mesure était évalué par le
réseau des coopératives Enercoop à 450
000 euros en 2014 et au plus un million
d'euros en 2016 avec un effet de levier
permettant de lever jusqu'à 6 millions
d'euros d'investissement dans les
énergies renouvelables donc vous voyez
entre même un million et 6 millions
c'est en tous les cas une proposition
dynamique alors j'attends la réponse du
rapporteur général merci merci chers
collègues monsieur rapporteur général
la commission
de rapporteur général partage tout à
fait l'objectif de l'amendement mais
comme pour l'ISF PME il considère que
l'avantage matelas qui permet au
contribuable de réduire son IR en
investissant en capital des PME n'est
pas à nos yeux le bon outil
car il est destiné à favoriser la prise
de risque et ne doit donc pas se cumuler
avec une garantie tarifaire je rappelle
d'ailleurs que les entreprises
solidaires tout comme ce type de
production d'énergie bénéficie déjà de
divers avantages fiscaux spécifiques et
dans ces conditions là aussi je demande
le retrait de l'amendement pour les
motifs déjà évoqués si monsieur le
rapporteur général madame la ministre
même avis je vous remercie monsieur
gatelin même retrait
oui même retrait je demanderai quand
même un moment rapportant général qu'on
sorte la boîte à outils alternative à un
moment donné on aura l'occasion je pense
de le faire et de le refaire mais je
retire merci chers
le 85 rectifié bis monsieur Dassault
vous le présentez
plus de 12 ans après son installation
par vos prédécesseurs la prime pour
l'emploi est une dépense qui était
prévue pour insulter le chômeur à des
misés par 24 mois à taux plein à bien
vouloir accepter un emploi dans le
soleil l'ensemble insuffisant par
rapport à ce qu'il touche on ne
travaille pas
le rapport la Cour des comptes
l'inspection générale des finances
saumontre les critiques quant au bilan
de la prime de l'emploi pour son impact
sur l'emploi d'après le projet de loi de
finances pour 2014 le coût de cette
prime pour l'emploi pour le budget
d'État devrait s'élever à 2,2 milliards
et c'est élevé à 2,3 pour le budget de
2013 c'est une somme considérable qui ne
crée aucun emploi nouveau et qui
s'apparente plus à l'aide sociale un
exemple donné par accord des comptes
montre que célibataire prenant un emploi
énuméré au SMIC à 100 cette prime pour
l'emploi 67 euros de revenus
supplémentaires par rapport à ce qu'il
touche de travail en panne et 180 avec
cette prime ça prouve que l'inactivité
est trop payé par rapport à l'activité
et que pour inciter les chômeurs à bien
vouloir reprendre un travail il serait
plus utile de réduire le temps de
financement du chômage que de leur
donner une prime pour accepter de
travailler Madame le Ministre le prime
pour l'emploi est une dépense que je
vous propose de supprimer et qui vous
permettra de disposer de 2 milliards de
plus pour votre budget pour les utiliser
pour d'autres activités pour vous éviter
de nouveaux impôts et pour réduire votre
déficit budgétaire voilà ce que je vous
propose de la ministre pour votre bien
pour le bien de votre budget et pour les
économies que vous pourriez faire je
vous remercie monsieur Dassault je vous
remercie monsieur Dassault monsieur le
rapporteur général votre avis sur cet
amendement et bien la vie est bien sûr
défavorable puisque notre collègue Serge
Dassault nous propose un amendement qui
a déjà fait l'objet donc d'une
discussion en PLF pour 2014 pour lequel
j'avais donné un avis défavorable et
bien entendu il s'agit avec cet
amendement chers collègues de préconiser
une baisse de pouvoir d'achat de 2,2
milliards d'euros pour les ménages les
plus modestes de notre pays donc bien
entendu on ne peut être favorable à
votre amendement puisque certains de vos
collègues dans votre groupe n'arrêtent
pas de souligner depuis le début de la
discussion que le gouvernement par les
dispositifs qui met en place
tente à introduire un processus récessif
en France diminuer le pouvoir d'achat
comme vous le proposez 2 milliards deux
va dans le sens de ces mesures que vos
collègues ne cessent de critiquer ou de
mettre en cause donc voyez les
contradictions les contradictions elles
sont pas de ce côté elles sont plutôt
chez vous et en toute état de cause bien
entendu la vie que je peux donner est
défavorable si monsieur le rapporteur
général madame la ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur évidemment nous le gouvernement
ne peut pas vous suivre non plus dans
cette voie pour les raisons qui viennent
d'être exposées par le rapporteur
général et qui tiennent à la
préservation du pouvoir d'achat des
ménages les plus modestes donc je
n'ajouterai que un ou deux un ou deux
points tout d'abord la réforme du couple
prime pour l'emploi RSA proposé par le
rapport sirugues qui a été remis au
Premier ministre le 15 juillet 2013 et
qui examine différence scénarios et
formule plusieurs propositions en faveur
des travailleurs modestes constituent
des pistes de travail pour le
gouvernement et notamment pour la
ministre en charge des personnes
handicapées et de la lutte contre
l'exclusion et donc je précise que la
prime pour l'emploi est bien un des
sujets qui a vocation à être abordé dans
le cadre du débat sur la fiscalité qui a
été annoncée par le Premier ministre
donc nous sommes également défavorables
à cette amendement je vous remercie
madame la ministre monsieur le Président
Marini vous avez la parole
je souhaitais
dire un mot sur le vote favorable que je
m'apprête à émettre sur l'amendement de
Monsieur Serge Dassault la prime pour
l'emploi c'est un dispositif déjà
relativement ancien puisqu'il remonte à
la fin du gouvernement Jospin
et beaucoup de questions
se sont posées sur son effectivité sur
son caractère incitatif
ceci en raison du décalage qui
intervient nécessairement dans son
versement par rapport à la période de
référence la prime pour l'emploi ne peut
être versée que au cours de l'année N+1
et
c'est un c'est un mécanisme qui au
moment où il se traduit par des
versements aux intéressés a souvent peu
de chances d'être rapproché de la
situation où les 10 intéressés pouvaient
se trouver au moment du calcul de la
prime ceci a été observé par de très
nombreux observateurs
économistes et auteur de rapports
administratifs
j'ajoute que le gouvernement auquel vous
appartenez madame la ministre a déjà
réduit très sensiblement la prime pour
l'emploi puisque du fait de la
non-indexation des barèmes de l'impôt
sur le revenu pendant deux années sauf
erreur de ma part son coût global est à
diminuer de 2,9 à 2,2 milliards d'euros
donc ceci est bien une mesure que vous
avez prise vous avez réduit de 700
millions d'euros cette distribution de
pouvoir d'achat à mon sens
si l'on faisait ce que dit Serge
Dassault voire un peu moins c'est à dire
si l'on réduisait encore de mettons 500
millions d'euros la prime pour l'emploi
on ferait certainement quelque chose de
raisonnable et rien de particulier ne se
passerait dans notre économie donc en un
temps où il faut s'efforcer de veiller à
l'efficacité de la dépense publique à
mon avis ce serait une bonne voie à
suivre alors j'ajoute en réponse à notre
excellent rapporteur général que la
logique des membres de ce côté-ci de
notre assemblée n'est pas tout à fait
analogue à celle des membres en ce
moment moins nombreux de l'autre côté de
l'Assemblée car ce matin nous avons voté
en faveur de l'exonération des heures
supplémentaires n'est-ce pas et ça c'est
du pouvoir d'achat alors qu'on ne nous
reproche pas de négliger le pouvoir
d'achat de nos concitoyens
merci monsieur le Président Marini y
a-t-il d'autres demandes de parole
monsieur Dassault vous avez la parole
oui je trouve dommage que alors que le
premier ministre cherche à réduire les
dépenses de l'État il n'utilise pas
cette proposition pour avoir 2 milliards
de plus dans son budget pour une
opération qui n'existe pas et qui est
quand même amoral de vouloir donner de
l'argent à des gens qui ne veulent pas
travailler parce que ils trouvent qu'il
ne gagne pas assez donc Madame le
Ministre pour vous pour la France pour
le budget je persiste à vous demander de
mieux vouloir voter cet amendements
merci
vous êtes amendement je n'en vois pas je
vais le mettre au a et merci je vais le
mettre au bois et je suis saisie
d'inscritin d'une demande de scrutin
public
manque de manière
scrutin public sur l'amendement 85
rectifié bis par le groupe socialiste
l'amendement de la commission et
défavorable au monde du gouvernement et
défavorable il va donc être procédé au
scrutin public dans les conditions
fixées par l'article 56 du règlement le
scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
plus personne
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est donc l'eau j'invite les
critères à procéder au dépouillement
résultat du scrutin numéro 5 sur
l'amendement numéro 85 rectifié tendante
à assurer un article additionnel après
l'article 10 du projet de loi nombre de
votants 345 nombre de suffrages exprimés
316 pour l'adoption 139 contre 177 le
Sénat n'a pas adopté
un amendement 176 qui est présenté par
notre collègue alphonsey
ante madame la ministre
cet amendement concernant des services à
la personne
je rappelle que ce secteur représente
plus d'un million d'emplois dans notre
pays
et qui est également un vecteur de
solidarité je pense notamment au service
destinés au maintien à leur domicile des
personnes âgées dépendantes
comme d'autres il a été durement touché
par la crise économique et en 2011 le
nombre d'heures d'emploi à domicile
rémunérés par les particuliers
AVC pour la première fois de 1,8%
. alors aujourd'hui plusieurs mesures
comme la hausse de la TVA et celle des
charges sociales conduisent à une
recrudescence de l'activité non déclarée
dans ce secteur pour éviter le
développement du travail au noir que
certaines études chiffres à 12% notre
amendement propose d'exclure les
réductions d'impôts accordés au titre de
l'emploi d'un salarié à domicile du
plafonnement global des niches fiscales
dix chers collègues la vie du de la
commission mais sur la portière générale
maintenant la présidente mes chers
collègues là aussi c'est un amendement
qui vient après avoir été évoqué au PLF
qui était à l'époque présenté par le
groupe udi et je ne peux que donner le
même avis défavorable c'est amendement
car il augmenterait le coût d'une
dépense fiscale qui est déjà conséquente
et il bénéficierait surtout au contribua
percevant les revenus les plus élevés ça
résume donc une position claire c'est de
considérer que ce n'est pas opportun de
d'aller dans cette direction donc c'est
un avis défavorable de la commission
merci Monsieur le rapport
EUR
mais ma vie je vous remercie
oui monsieur d'Allier
si madame la Présidente nous allons
soutenir cet amendement et nous voterons
pour nous l'avions déjà fait lors du
débat en loi de finance initial pour
2014 effectivement le travail au noir
appelons comme cela redémarre ces
manifeste c'est certainement dû
effectivement à l'augmentation des
charges et des impôts sur ces emplois à
domicile et voilà pourquoi il nous
semble que le jeu vaut la chandelle
madame la ministre nous pouvons
effectivement accepter cette dépense
parce que je suis certain qu'au bout du
compte il y aura aussi des recettes en
face
très bien y a-t-il d'autres demandes de
parole je n'en vois pas je vais donc
mettre au voile amendement
je reviens aux arguments développés par
notre collègue pour rappeler que
la mesure en question
j'insiste lourdement là-dessus
bénéficierait principalement
contribuable percevant les revenus les
plus élevés et j'attire votre attention
sur le fait que le comité d'évaluation
des dépenses fiscales et des niches
sociales avait ainsi évalué que les 80%
des foyers les moins riches ne
bénéficiaient que de 8% de la dépense
fiscale totale relative au service à la
personne c'est je crois très clairement
démontré que on est ici face à une
situation où aller dans le sens de
dispositif proposé d'exclusion des
services à la personne et de l'emploi à
domicile du plafonnement global des
réductions des crédits d'impôts
favoriserait très clairement très
clairement
les catégories sociales les plus
favorisées en termes de situations de
revenus et dans ces conditions
j'insiste sur l'avis défavorable de la
commission au regard de cet argument qui
me paraît calme un argument relativement
fort
merci monsieur le rapporteur général
monsieur Delattre vous avez la parole
simplement pour elle pour expliquer à
Monsieur rapporteur général que
peut-être c'est effectivement il y a une
dépense immédiate mais nous sommes
persuadés que il y a un retour et en
plus il y a le problème de l'emploi
parce que c'est quand même l'emploi
d'ailleurs ce matin Aubry qui avait mis
les premiers systèmes en place il y a du
temps d'un gouvernement qui ne veut pas
être de droite et je trouve que ça avait
créé des milliers d'emplois donc
moins de travail
clandestin et plus d'emplois ça mérite
un peu mieux qu'un verre de main de
notre rapport en général
simplement pour répondre aux rapports
général
il est très difficile d'utiliser des
statistiques
brutalement ça profite à 80% de riches
et puis il y en a qui au moins 20% pour
ceux qui n'ont pas de revenus importants
c'est un peu rapide si j'ose m'exprimer
ainsi je crois qu'il faut mettre en
balance l'ensemble des éléments de pour
bien apprécier la portée cet amendement
le travail noir est-ce qu'il est en
balance avec la statistique on ne le
sait pas je crois que la réalité c'est
que à partir du moment où cette niche
disparaît on va avoir une tendance très
forte au travail noir et le bilan en
quelque sorte l'impact n'est pas encore
établi pour savoir si c'est un lentement
est un détestable ou pas je crois que
pour le voter c'est tout
si elles font si je le mets donc aux
voix deux avis défavorables de
l'amendement présenté par Monsieur
Alfonsi qui est pour
merci contre
merci il est adopté
après l'article 10 j'ai un amendement 35
rectifié bis et Monsieur Dallier qu'il
présente merci madame la Présidente mes
chers collègues alors voilà certainement
un amendement d'appel mais qui vise à
poser un problème bien réel qui est
celui des rentrées TVA sur le commerce
en ligne vous vous souvenez certainement
qu'il y a quelques semaines un rapport à
avancer des chiffres en matière de
d'évaporation de la base de TVA au
niveau européen bon le chiffre de 32
milliards étaient avancé pour la France
c'est un chiffre très important qui a
été contesté par la Commission
européenne mais même si ça n'était pas à
32 milliards même si ça n'était qu'une
dizaine de milliards on voit bien là
qu'il y a des enjeux très importants et
nous avons donc souhaité avec mon
collègue albéric de Montgolfier nous
intéresser à cette problématique et
essayer de proposer une solution qui
permettent effectivement de garantir
qu'au moment où un achat effectué sur
Internet et bien la part de TVA qui est
bien payé par le consommateur retombe
bien dans les caisses de l'État c'est
effectivement un vrai souci notamment
lorsque les sociétés qui vendent ces
produits sont domiciliés à l'étranger
que ça soit à l'intérieur de la
Communauté européenne ou à l'extérieur
de la Communauté européenne l'État n'est
jamais certain effectivement que la TVA
est bien reversé alors est-ce qu'il y a
des moyens techniques pour essayer de
trouver une solution à cette
problématique et bien nous pensons que
oui et il pourrait être étudié une
solution qui consisterait effectivement
à faire en sorte que la TVA soit
reversée au moment même où l'achat est
conclu et où le comte du Client est
débité à partir du moment de ce moment
là le montant hors taxes du produit
serait transféré au vendeur et la partie
TVA serait directement versée sur un
compte du Trésor techniquement ça nous
semble tout à fait faisable alors certes
il y a certainement un problème au
niveau du droit européen c'est pour ça
que je parle d'un amendement d'appel il
y a des choses à creuser mais si nous
voulons effectivement trouver une
solution à ce vrai problème de
l'evorable de l'évaporation de la base
imposable en matière de TVA je pense
qu'il est grand temps d'y réfléchir les
ventes en ligne explose et de manière
presque exponentielle nous avons vu
cette année que les rentrées de TVA
baisse alors ça n'est certainement pas
dans les proportions constatées en
raison de la vente en ligne uniquement
de la vente en ligne mais on peut
effectivement penser que dans les années
qui viennent ce phénomène va s'amplifier
et si le gouvernement veut effectivement
essayer de faire quelque chose il faut
que ce problème soit posé alors bien
évidemment il y a le problème de droit
au niveau européen il faut mettre aussi
autour de la table toutes les banques et
les tiers de confiance en matière de
paiement je crois Madame le Ministre que
nous avons là un vrai sujet à regarder
et voilà pourquoi au travers de cet
amendement nous avons voulu vous faire
cette proposition
qu'en pense notre rapporteur général au
nom de la Commission
madame la Présidente c'est là un très
très bon sujet et notre collègue
Philippe d'allier l'a montré d'ailleurs
récemment dans le rapport qu'il a fait
avec son collègue de Montgolfier au nom
de la commission des finances il a
montré qu'une partie importante de la
TVA due sur les ventes en ligne de bien
matériel échappe à l'état en raison de
l'impossibilité matérielle dans
contrôler les flux physique mais aussi
les flux financiers et comme vous l'avez
dit chers collègues c'est un secteur en
forte croissance puisque pour le dernier
semestre c'est plus 15%
d'augmentation de chiffres sur ces
transactions dès lors évidemment les
pertes peuvent être importantes droites
douane n'impose sur les sociétés ou
encore l'impôt sur le revenu bref il y a
là un vrai problème
quant à la proposition vous faites de
prélever la TVA à l'importation par les
banques au moment de la transaction elle
est certainement une piste très
intéressante et la commission des
finances souhaitait à cet égard
s'assurer des modalités de la
faisabilité de la mise en oeuvre d'un
tel mode de
recouvrement et nous avons souhaité
avoir l'avis du gouvernement d'un
ministre sur ce sujet particulièrement
sensible et à nos yeux très importants
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Sénateur vous soulevez effectivement une
question extrêmement importante et le
Gouvernement partage tout à fait votre
souci de sécuriser la perception de la
TVA sur ses flux de marchandises cela
étant il ne peut soutenir et vous l'avez
bien perçu vous-même soutenir votre
demande pour les raisons que je vais
vous exposer alors tout d'abord
s'agissant de la TVA elle ne peut y
avoir de solution vous le savez bien
nationales et isolée la solution ne peut
être élaborée que dans le cadre
communautaire or le droit communautaire
en vigueur n'autorise pas à modifier le
frais générateur de la TVA qui est dû au
titre des importations de bien la mise
en oeuvre d'une telle disposition ne
pourrait conduire qu'à un contentieux
qu'il serait extrêmement difficile de
gagner par ailleurs la Commission qui a
mené des travaux sur ce sujet n'a pas à
ce jour trouver une solution à ce
problème qui soit de nature à satisfaire
tous les États membres et puis enfin
l'intermédiaire de paiement qui peut ne
pas être situé sur le territoire
français ce qui constituerait une
difficulté pratique supplémentaire
n'aurait pas obligatoirement à sa
disposition les informations pertinentes
qui lui permettrait de savoir si la
transaction en cause porte bien sur un
bien pour lequel il doit collecter la
TVA ou sur un service pour lequel il ne
la connecte pas donc le gouvernement
pour répondre à votre amendement d'appel
s'engage à demander au service de la
commission Europe européenne de
réactiver de manière très active la
réflexion sur le sujet qui avait été mis
en sommeil fin 2011 et pour ces raisons
je vous demande monsieur le sénateur de
bien vouloir retirer votre amendement à
défaut j'en demanderai le rejet merci
madame la ministre
monsieur le Président de la Commission
la présidente la ministre j'aurais
souhaité en effet dire quelques mots sur
ce sujet et appuyé d'ailleurs le propos
qui a été tenu par le rapporteur général
car c'est bien à l'issue d'un contrôle
mené au nom de la commission des
finances que nos collègues d'alliés et
de Montgolfier se sont intéressés en se
rendant au bureau de douane de Roissy
aux conditions dans lesquelles les
marchandises importés dans le cadre du
commerce électronique faisait l'objet de
contrôle et à partir de cela
à partir des constatations factuelles
auxquelles ils se sont livrés
plusieurs séries d'éléments sont apparus
d'abord madame la ministre et ceci
ressort directement des responsabilités
de votre collègue Bernard Cazeneuve
s'agissant de l'organisation de la
direction générale des douanes de son
efficacité pour tâcher de mieux
maîtriser la problématique du contrôle
de tel flux il y a manifestement des
progrès à faire
dans la douane classique
lorsque la valeur
d'une marchandise
déclarée
pouvait
faire l'objet de différentes
interprétations il y avait un tiers qui
était le déclarant et qui répondait de
la valeur déclarée devant
l'administration et en matière de
commerce électronique il n'est pas
possible et de procéder ainsi du moins
jusqu'ici et
Philippe d'allier et albéric de
Montgolfier faisait figurer dans leur
rapport et dans les annexes la
reproduction de pièces la reproduction
de factures qui par exemple émanait
portateur de de matériel chinois en
grande quantité et qui valorisait à des
tarifs
incroyablesment bas des articles
destinés au marché français et il est
bien clair que les effectifs de la
direction générale des douanes
l'organisation de celle-ci la manière
dont les contrôles peuvent être exercés
sur de tels flux ne représentent
absolument pas aujourd'hui une réponse
appropriée aux enjeux et donc il y a là
un premier sujet qui est d'adapter
l'organisation administrative et les
priorités du contrôle et c'est en
quelque sorte un signal d'alarme que
nous voulons allumer par le rapport qui
a été publié par collègues au nom de la
commission des finances et également par
cette amendement d'appel donc nous
souhaiterions vraiment qu'il y ait de la
part de l'administration
des mesures concrètes qui soient prises
pour se réorganiser et pour tâcher
d'obtenir plus déficient car nous avons
l'intuition que les enjeux en termes de
droit à rappeler sont réellement très
importants même si nous ne sommes pas en
mesure de les chiffrer ensuite il y a un
second aspect qui est celui directement
traité par l'amendement et qui relative
au mode de versement de la TVA la
proposition qui est faite nous en avons
bien inconscience mérite d'être analysé
au regard du droit communautaire mais
faut-il dans ce domaine comme dans
d'autres attendre madame la ministre
l'accord unanime qui n'interviendra
jamais de 28
ayant des intérêts contradictoires
est-ce que nous devons nous résigner à
cela ou est-ce qu'il ne faut pas
rechercher
dans le cadre de l'Union européenne la
construction de position commune
entre quelques états entre les
principaux États intéressés ne
faudrait-il pas que la France soit en
quelque sorte volontariste dans cette
recherche de plus d'équité fiscale
international car si j'ai bien entendu
notre excellent rapporteur général
rappeler l'impératif de la justice au
sens de la répartition au sein de notre
pays il me semble que dans le monde des
entreprises et au plan international
s'efforcer de parvenir à plus de justice
à plus d'équité est également un
impératif catégorique donc nous serions
heureux madame la ministre que vous
puissiez
nous dire peut-être dans quelle mesure
il serait possible de cheminer ensemble
pour améliorer les méthodes de travail
et pour rechercher des solutions
raisonnables car
l'échange que nous avons eu dans un an
dans deux ans dans trois ans
n'aurons-nous pas le même et dans
l'intervalle combien de recettes combien
de milliards d'euros manqueront-ils à la
pelle
monsieur le Président de la Commission
merci madame la Présidente je veux aller
dans le même sens et dire que c'est une
question importante que que vous
soulevez dont nous sommes je crois tous
conscients et celui-ci d'ailleurs
m'amène à lier cette proposition à un
autre débat qui est celui sur
l'autoliquidation de la TVA à
l'importation qui est un débat difficile
qui dure depuis assez nombreuses années
qui est de savoir si les entreprises qui
importent doivent acquitter la TVA au
moment où le bien rentre sur le
territoire communautaire ou si on leur
permet ou si on permet au fond au bien
de circuler et d'acquitter la TVA au
lieu final de de consommation
et on sait bien que dans ce cas là se
met en place des fraudes massives qu'on
appelle les carrousels ou la marchandise
circule suffisamment pour être perdu de
vue et la TVA s'évapore et il y a
plusieurs probablement plusieurs
milliards d'euros qui disparaissent
comme c'est mais c'est un débat
difficile d'abord parce que c'est un
débat communautaire et malheureusement
monsieur le Président je crois pas qu'on
puisse le faire dans le cadre de
coopération renforcée moi je serai je
serais pour si on pouvait le faire à
quelques-uns pour avancer ça serait bien
mais il me semble que c'est un une
compétence de l'Union et puis l'autre
problème c'est que nous rentrons dans
une de ces grandes querelles
bureaucratiques que la France connaît
bien qui est celle entre
l'Administration des Douanes et
l'administration des impôts des impôts
disant la TVA c'est moi et on veut pas
que ça soit les douanes qui s'occupe de
la TVA et on est parti pour au tout le
même débat que sur le rapprochement de
la CSG et de l'IRPP donc il y a un
troisième débat je veux pas trop
rallonger mais il y a un troisième débat
qui rejoint celui là qui est le fait le
fait que les sites de vente en ligne
servent de plus en plus à la vente de
produits de contrefaçon et on est nous
sommes tous à la recherche ministre on a
parlé l'autre jour à l'assemblée du
Knack à la recherche de méthode qui
permettrait de frapper si j'ose dire les
les sites et les ceux qui vendent des
produits de contrefaçon en particulier
par les moyens de paiement comme vous
dites par les réseaux Paypal les réseaux
bancaires les réseaux
les réseaux de d'aguments donc on
rejoindrait au fond sur un autre sujet
votre votre proposition mais je crois
que là on a un ensemble de sujets très
importants sur lesquels il faut vraiment
avancer maintenant
merci Monsieur young monsieur gatelin
merci madame la Présidente je voudrais
continuer dans cette réflexion là parce
que on a le cas effectivement alors les
consommateurs souvent ne se plaignent
pas de d'avoir des produits qui viennent
en importation via Internet moins cher
mais il y a aussi des conséquences pour
nos entreprises et nos industries dans
un monde qui devient dématérialisé et
des territorialisés alors j'ai payé la
chance d'accompagner messieurs Dallier
et Montgolfier aux douanes de Roissy
mais j'ai plusieurs fois la chance
d'accompagner madame la ministre de
l'économie numérique dans des
entreprises de jeux vidéo et c'est vrai
que il y a la production aujourd'hui de
jeux vidéo qui sont diffusés sur des
plateformes type Facebook Amazon ou
steam etc
étrangère où ce sont des jeux qui sont
produits par des sociétés françaises
alors où tes droits d'entrée qu'on leur
demande qu'ils ont très élevés on ne
leur dit pas la provenance finale des
achats donc quand il se retrouve devant
la nuit ces petites sociétés qui sont
des PME très innovantes très
performantes qui vont sur un marché
ultra concurrentiel quand elles vendent
10000 jeux elle se retrouve taxée à 19,6
sur l'ensemble des ventes qui sont
faites simplement parce que ces
opérateurs refusent de leur donner la
provenance des ventes alors certains
comme facebook dit on va vous arranger
un tarif préférentiel mais là je crois
qu'on a des PME PMI qui se cassent la
figure simplement parce que pour le coup
elle elle paie plus de TVA que ce
qu'elle devrait payer et ça pose un vrai
problème parce que quand on discute avec
l'administration fiscale soit on est
capable d'être suffisamment fort face à
Apple Facebook ou steam c'est très
difficile soit un moment il va falloir
arriver à dire bien on considère qu'il y
a un prorata prorata contenu de la
nature plus ou moins internationale
multilingue du produit on va considérer
qu'il y a pas plus de 50% qui a été
vendu sur le territoire français et
faire quelque chose de forfaitaire
quelque chose qui est impensable il faut
bien le dire dans le système des impôts
français et c'est bien dommage parce
qu'on a tout un tas de petites
entreprises novatrices dynamique
aujourd'hui sont dévorés par
cette nouvelle façon de gérer l'économie
non seulement des territorialisés mais
en plus dématérialisé et je dis là c'est
un des enjeux qu'on aborder avec mon
collègue Bruno Retailleau dans notre
rapport sur l'industrie du jeu vidéo et
ça nous a été rappelé plusieurs fois je
prends la ministre pour témoin à
Bordeaux dans les entreprises qu'on a
visité de jeux vidéo ou du numérique et
là il va falloir qu'on ait une réflexion
qu'on repense il va falloir aussi que
nos administrations fiscale dans ce pays
accepte de se repenser on ne gouverne
plus un pays au 21e siècle comme on le
veut gouverner au 19e siècle au 20e
siècle on ne peut plus concevoir l'impôt
de la même manière qu'on la concevait
quand il y avait des barrières
douanières quand il y avait des services
de douane donc il faut réinventer
quelque chose plutôt que dire à chaque
fois c'est impossible c'est impossible
ou en tous les cas on va avoir du mal à
faire comprendre à cette brave
administration fiscale qu'elle ne doit
pas changer ou des douanes merci si
Monsieur gatolin monsieur Dallier vous
avez été sollicité pour le retrait de
votre amendement que décidez-vous madame
la ministre madame la Présidente je
crois que notre débat aura au moins
démontré que tout le monde est bien
inconscient des enjeux et ce n'est pas à
la ministre en charge de l'économie
numérique que je ferai l'injure de
d'expliquer ou d'essayer d'expliquer que
le monde change très vite que les mondes
de consommation les modes de
consommation changent très vite et que
nous avons beaucoup de difficultés à
nous adapter alors bien évidemment c'est
un sujet qui doit être traité au niveau
européen mais alors il sera probablement
difficile de trouver le consensus comme
le disait monsieur le Président de la
Commission est finance ceci étant dit
tous les pays européens sont a priori
confrontés à la même problématique ça
n'est pas une spécialité française que
d'être confronté à cet évaporation de la
base taxable donc ils y ont tous intérêt
à mon avis faut-il effectivement qu'un
gouvernement prenne l'initiative et une
initiative forte pour reposer le débat
donc je compte sur vous j'ai bien
entendu votre engagement de le faire et
j'espère que nous pourrons aboutir
relativement rapidement
techniquement je pense que c'est tout à
fait faisable ça n'est pas du tout
insurmontable voilà il suffit d'associer
effectivement les banques les
intermédiaires et de fixer des règles
alors commençons par fixer les règles
après le problème technique à mon sens
se réglera à ses aimants je retire cette
amendement merci Monsieur Dallier madame
la ministre vous voulez rajouter un mot
merci madame la Présidente Justin un
petit mot pour expliquer un peu ce qui a
été fait jusqu'à présent et ne pas
donner l'impression que le gouvernement
a été inactif sur ce sujet bien au
contraire comme vous le savez il y a eu
le 24 et le 25 octobre dernier un
Conseil européen chef d'État et de chef
de gouvernement consacrés à l'innovation
et à l'économie numérique et à
l'occasion de ce conseil nous avons été
mes services en particulier extrêmement
actifs pour mettre la question de la
fiscalité à l'air numérique sur la table
des discussions de ce conseil vous savez
que c'est cette question de la fiscalité
numérique porte sur plusieurs aspects
l'impôt sur les sociétés d'une part qui
lui aussi fait l'objet d'une érosion des
bases très très considérable et puis la
question de la TVA sur très bien
physique qui sont commercialisées par le
biais de plateforme numérique et puis
sur les biens dématérialisés et donc sur
les biens des matérialisés il y a une
échéance en 2015 puisque la
territorialisation la TVA change à
partir de cet échéance et que la TVA a
quitté sera désormais celle du pays du
consommateur à partir de 2015 et
progressivement jusqu'en 2018 sur les
biens physiques auxquels vous faisiez
allusion nous souhaitons effectivement
que le groupe de travail qui a sur notre
initiative l'initiative française était
créée par la commission par le
commissaire chez meta groupe de travail
qui s'intéresse donc à la fiscalité
numérique puisse s'intéresser et
appréhender ces questions de bien
physique qui sont commercialisés par des
plateformes trop de manière
transfrontalière de la même façon que ce
groupe de travail sera très attentif à
dégager des solutions sur l'impôt sur
les sociétés et le problème
considérables pour les pays qui se
cherchent à redresser leur finance
publique d'érosion des bases dont
souffre vous l'avez dit pas seulement la
France mais les autres pays et je suis
moi-même très mobilisé pour essayer de
trouver des points de convergence avec
mes homologues chargés de l'économie
numérique dans divers pays pour essayer
d'avancer je sais que l'unanimité est
difficile à réunir sur les questions
fiscales à l'échelle européenne mais
néanmoins pour trouver des points de
convergence avec de grands alliés qui
pourraient nous aider à faire avancer ce
débat
merci Madame la Ministre un amendement
71 madame Beaufils
madame la présidente madame la ministre
chers collègues à revenir sur le montant
des abattements successoraux adopté dans
le cadre de la loi TEPA du 21 août 2016
tout en maintenant le principe de
doublement de la battement au bénéfice
des héritiers légataires ou donataire
incapable de travailler dans des
conditions normales de rentabilité en
raison d'une infirmité physique ou
mentale congénitale ou acquise
si la vie de notre rapporteur général
sur un rendement présenté par madame
Beaufils le 71 c'est ça
merci la vie de la Commission a
défavorable
parce que la comique parce que
l'amendement remet une nouvelle fois sur
le tapis l'un des éléments de la réforme
de la fiscalité du patrimoine que nous
avons voté l'année dernière et
sur le fond je considère donc c'est
amendement étant déjà en grande partie
satisfait par la réforme du collectif
budgétaire de l'été 2012 pour mémoire
les abattements ont alors été diminués
passant de près de 160.000 euros à
100.000 euros et le délai de reprise des
donations a été portée de 10 à 15 ans et
le rendement de l'ensemble de ces
mesures est estimée après de 1,5
milliards d'euros en année pleine bon
donc je considère que le travail a déjà
été fait pour l'essentiel et il me
semble pas opportun de reprendre un tel
débat aujourd'hui et la vie est donc
défavorable
mais ma vie mesdames la ministre je vous
remercie je vais mettre au voie cet
amendement qui a eu deux avis
défavorables qui est pour merci contre
merci mes chers collègues abstention il
n'est pas adopté après l'article 10 un
amendement 73 présente également par
madame Beaufils
oui madame la présidente madame la
ministre notre amendement revient sur
une position de fond que nous avons
souvent exprimé ici c'est la suppression
du dispositif du Treil et les
dispositifs proches qui sont d'un coup
très lourd pour nos finances publiques
et qui mine de le rendement de l'impôt
de solidarité sur la fortune nous
pensons en effet qu'il faut remettre à
plat notre système de prélèvement s'il
faut remettre à plat notre système de
prélèvement obligatoire les niches
fiscales doivent être particulièrement
présente dans cette rectification donc
trois niches sont issues du même texte
la loi du Treil qui réduisent de 261
millions d'euros le produit de l'impôt
de solidarité sur la fortune et c'est ce
dispositif qui vient en effet ce
superposé de manière
inutile aux multiples exon
dont souffre les SF et continue à miner
une recette fiscale dont le dynamisme et
la réalité mériterait d'être encouragée
plutôt que il se complètent avec
le dispositif et sfpme dispositif
coûteuse je rappelle ça soit 570
millions d'euros prévus en 2014 pour un
peu plus de 40 000 ménages dont
l'efficience demeure approuver qui
constitue au regard des autres
incitations fiscales à l'investissement
fonds propres dans les entreprises
l'opération la plus gourmande en fond
public difficultés supplémentaires pour
les dispositions du Treil l'évaluation
des voies et moyens permet de connaître
l'ampleur de la dépense fiscale mais ne
permet plus aujourd'hui de déterminer le
nombre des bénéficiaires il a surtout
été invoqué pour lutter contre les deux
localisations fiscales ce qui ne veut
évidemment
ce qui ne peut évidemment manquer de
nous faire sourire puisque malgré cela
une bonne partie des membres de la
famille Mulliez à tout de même et migré
en Belgique ou que le PDG du groupe
Accor a préféré résider en Suisse où il
s'accommodent fort bien de légère
contrainte du forfait fiscal donc le
dispositif du trait n'a en fait été
sollicité que par des contribuables
avertis conseillés et de fait
relativement plus fortunés que les
autres il crée une évidente inégalité de
traitement en tractionnaire soumis à les
SF et actionnaires qui ne seraient pas
c'est pourquoi il nous semble que les
uns disposent d'un avantage comparatif
plus important que les autres alors
qu'ils sont justement plus riches donc
c'est pourquoi nous vous proposons cet
amendement
beau fils la vie de notre rapporteur
général au nom de la commission la vie
est défavorable puisque l'amendement a
déjà été déposé en PLF l'argumentation
développée reste la même puisque
on va à l'encontre du principe de
stabilité fiscale qui est préconisée
pour aider à l'investissement dans les
PME et bien entendu
je ne peux qu'être défavorable comme je
l'ai été pour le PLF je vous remercie
monsieur le rapporteur même avis je vous
remercie madame la ministre deux avis
défavorables pour cet amendement qui est
pour voter cet amendement madame
Beaufils merci contre
je vous remercie mes chers collègues
abstention il n'est pas adopté vous
présenter le suivant le 68 madame
Beaufils
oui merci
madame la Présidente donc il s'agit de
mettre en place un plafonnement du
plafonnement de l'ISF tel qu'il existait
auparavant j'ai bien entendu que
monsieur le rapporteur
considéré que c'était plus en loi de
finance initiale que ce type de question
devait se poser je rappelle que notre
proposition permettrait de plafonner le
plafonnement à 50% des sommes dus qui
auraient comme conséquence de redresser
les comptes publics quand même d'un peu
plus de 150 millions pour le moins
si madame Beaufils la vie de notre
rapporteur général
toujours défavorable chers collègues cet
amendement
car la réforme de l'ISF a déjà été
accomplie l'année dernière
dans la cadre d'une réforme globale de
la fiscalité patrimoine patrimoniale
dont il ne convient pas me semble-t-il
de modifier l'équilibre chaque année et
je rappelle tout de même que la réforme
importante de l'année dernière a
rapporté plus d'un milliard d'euros à
l'État et dans ces conditions il ne me
semble pas opportun de procéder à un
nouvel ajustement dans l'immédiat la vie
est défavorable si Monsieur rapporteur
général mais ma vie madame la ministre
je vous remercie je mets aux voix cet
amendement deux avis défavorants madame
le beau-fils voulaient vous exprimer
j'ai bien entendu ce qu'a dit notre
rapporteur général en même temps si j'ai
bien vu dans dans les bilans il semble
bien que ce dispositif s'est
démontré d'un coup plus élevé cette
année la somme de 730 millions d'euros
quand même plus importantes que le
défunt bouclier fiscal de la loi TPA
enfin bon si mes chiffres sont exacts il
me semble bien que c'est c'est un peu
plus important ça veut dire qu'on a
peut-être pas complètement résolu le
problème
10 chers collègues et je mets donc on
voit l'amendement deux avis défavorables
qui est pour le voter merci contre
merci mes chers collègues abstention il
n'est pas adopté après l'article 10
trois amendements en discussion commune
trois amendements de Monsieur Dallier
monsieur Dallier vous pouvez les
présenter en continu bien volontiers
madame la Présidente
mes chers collègues c'est trois
amendements je les avais déposés en loi
de finances initiale pour 2014 mais nos
collègues communistes avaient déposé un
amendement de suppression de l'article
qui avait été adopté et donc je n'avais
pas eu le loisir de les défendre j'y
reviens donc ici alors de quoi s'agit-il
d'une disposition qui vise entre le 1er
septembre 2013 et le 31 août 2014 à
réduire l'imposition des plus-values de
cession sur les terrains autres que les
terrains à bâtir alors j'insiste sur ce
point qui est important puisque le
gouvernement nous présentait cette
disposition comme devant concourir à un
choc d'offres dans le cadre de la
relance de la politique du logement
alors il ne s'agit pas de terrain qui
pourront permettre de construire des
immeubles nouveaux on parle bien
d'appartement ou de maisons existantes
donc le choc d'offre pour effectivement
favoriser la construction de logements
nouveaux ça n'est pas de cela dont il
s'agit cette mesure va coûter et
l'amendement va donc si vous l'adopiez
effectivement faire faire des économies
à l'état parce qu'à mon sens il s'agit
tout simplement d'un effet d'aubaine
nous avons dans un rapport récent sur
les outils fonciers que nous avons rendu
avec mes collègues vont me dire end donc
piller et Colin travailler sur ces
sujets et assez bien démontré que dans
le passé toutes les mesures qui avaient
été présentées comme susceptibles de
déclencher un choc d'offre que ces
mesures s'étaient révélées inefficaces
et avaient au bout du compte
effectivement seulement profiter à
quelques-uns qui par le hasard se
trouvait de voir effectivement vendre un
bien à un moment même ou une fenêtre de
tir était ouverte pour bénéficier
effectivement d'un abattement ou
d'exonération donc voilà pourquoi je
vous propose ici de supprimer
cette disposition qui rapportera 145
millions enfin qui effectivement si vous
adoptez l'amendement rapporterait 145
millions au titre de l'impôt sur le
revenu et 100 millions ont-ils des
prélèvements sociaux si vous n'étiez pas
favorable à cet amendement vous avez
ensuite avec le 46 rectifier le 47
rectifié des amendements qu'on peut
qualifier de repli sur le même sujet
voilà pour cet examen du projet de loi
de finance rectificative pour 2013 les
sénateurs pourraient poursuivre les
discussions encore ce soir et demain
puisque l'ordre du jour est ouvert pour
le collectif budgétaire pendant tout le
week-end vous pouvez bien sûr toujours
voir et revoir toutes les séances sur
notre site public sénat.fr prochain
rendez-vous de l'actualité parlementaire
ce soir à 19h pour 24 heures Sénat avec
Marie brémo très bonne soirée à tous